depuis une semaine le chaos a de nouveau
envahi les rues de Port-au-Prince
peut avoir peur d'avoir faim et de
manquer de tout y compris d'eau potable
on en cherche partout et on ne trouve
rien les gangs qui bloquent des routes
empêchant la livraison de marchandises
et l'inflation galopante ont provoqué
des pénuries de presque toutes les
dangers
et les stations sont fermées depuis des
semaines c'est encore le coût de
l'essence qui a mis le feu aux poudres
la misère abjecte dans laquelle visite
un trop grand nombre de nos concitoyens
dans un rare discours à la nation le
Premier ministre a annoncé le 11
septembre la fin des subventions sur le
carburant résultat le prix de l'essence
à la pompe a plus que doublé d'un coup
une augmentation des prix équivaut à une
augmentation des prix des produits de
première nécessité
la colère populaire a explosé dans les
jours suivant l'annonce du Premier
ministre des affrontements ou barricades
ont fait au moins un mort et de nombreux
blessés et provoquer l'arrêt complet de
l'activité économique
et aujourd'hui la semaine dernière déjà
il y avait il y avait aucune activité
formée les informer le transport en
commun était à l'arrêt les banques
et aujourd'hui il y a des baguettes qui
sont levés mais cela ne produit pas une
reprise des activités les subventions
sur le carburant représentaient le quart
de tout le budget de l'État haïtien le
Fond Monétaire International a exigé
qu'elle soit supprimée en échange de son
appui financier mais le faire d'un seul
coup était risqué
dans les entreprises il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises qui vont enregistrer des
normes peuvent après ces mouvements de
contestation
manifestation intense et les plus sages
pour la sécurité du public et des
employés canadiens et locaux de
l'ambassade de fermer de fonctionner en
télétravail l'ambassade
ur est légitime il croit qu'il faut
continuer d'aider le pays à combattre
l'insécurité chronique la source de
tente souffrance c'est pourquoi le
premier ministre Trudeau présidera
demain à New York une réunion sur la
crise haïtienne le Premier ministre a
décidé de
convoquer cette réunion pour pouvoir
encourager d'autres partenaires à venir
avec nous pour renforcer la Police
nationale d'Haïti qui est selon nous la
solution pour l'insécuteur si la
situation sécuritaire s'améliore cela
permettrait aux Haïtiens de retourner
travailler et d'organiser des élections
car depuis plus d'un an les institutions
publiques comme le Parlement et les
tribunaux sont complètement
dysfonctionnelles ici ce fil en gloire
Radio-Canada Montréal